les républicains seront donc représentés
aux européennes par le trio
françois-xavier bennani agnès evren
arnaud danjean
il incarne ce qu'on veut faire un vrai
renouvellement
les nouveaux visages de la droite et ce
sont des personnalités qui portent de
vraies valeurs
françois-xavier bellamy il fait partie
précisément de cette droite des valeurs
il fait partie de ceux qui à l'image
d'alain finkielkraut ont eu le courage
de dénoncer la déconstruction du pays
par la pensée de 1968 il rejoint année
c'est vrai c'est une entrepreneuse
elle a remporté la fédération de paris
et elle fait partie de ces jeunes
talents auxquels je veux donner leur
chance
et enfin il ya 90 ans spécialiste des
questions de lutte contre le terrorisme
sujets essentiels spécialistes reconnus
au parlement européen les questions de
défense à trois cinquièmes le
rassemblement de la droite mais autour
d'une même vision oui à l'europe mais
non dégâts faits par la politique d'
emmanuel macron oui à l'europe et pour
la sauver il faut la changer
c'est le message que nous portons vous
êtes tous invités à apporter vos
contributions vos idées à participer
dans cette campagne des européennes